what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich so
that's us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
amazing
angel plenive i love amanova pompliano
p-i-m-p
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five lets
you earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in that interest-bearing account and you
can also sign up on the wait list for
the bitcoin rewards credit card you can
swipe your credit card and get bitcoin
back rather than cash back
or airline miles i'm an investor i sit
on the board i'm a very happy user and
you will be
too if you go to blockbuy.compomp
and sign up for an account today and
sign up for an account
today today dot com let's go
he was also very grumpy 30 seconds ago
the pending coinbase direct listing
scheduled for wednesday on the nasdaq
under the symbol coin is exciting a
broad base of the investment community
outside the usual cryptocurrency crowd
coinbase is going to blow people's minds
says
matt hogan chief investment officer of
bitwise asset management which pioneered
the first
crypto index fund i think it's going to
force traditional finance to wrestle
with the phenomenal growth that is
taking place in crypto do we agree or
disagree
well i definitely agree uh i think that
everyone is drastically underestimating
what has happened with coinbase
they did 600 million dollars in revenue
in q4 they did 1.8
billion in q1 they 3x their revenue
in a 90-day period it's nuts they did
more
revenue in q1 they did in all of 2020
and i think that they've got the macro
tailwind of bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
continuing
upwards and so i think this company is
going to come out of the gate
hot fast and it's not
i'm biased i have a little bit of
financial exposure my fingers are
crossed i'm not biased
come on let's go brian and team bang
bang what's up
you want do we want to make a guess as
to what we think it could hit this year
like stock price this is not financial
advice
this is not financially i don't want to
guess i don't speculate
but i would not be surprised
if we saw coinbase hit half a trillion
dollars
in market cap this year that to me feels
like
absolutely could happen make your own
decisions half a trillion dollars
not saying it's gonna happen but i'm not
saying that i'd be surprised if it did
next microsoft announced monday that it
will buy speech recognition company
nuance communications
for 60 for 56 dollars per share
which is about 23 above its closing
price on friday
the deal is worth about 16 billion
dollars
in about 19 billion including debt
what is microsoft doing well this is the
largest acquisition they've done since
linkedin
which is pretty interesting but it's a
lot
and it's also a larger acquisition than
the reported 10 billion
one that they wanted to do with discord
so the second you enter
into these large acquisitions you have
to ask yourself there's only three
reasons why somebody would
want to do this they're trying to either
buy the team they're trying to buy the
product
or they're trying to buy growth so it
looks like
microsoft is trying to buy the product
because nuance
actually sells tools for recognizing and
transcribing speech
and doctor office visits customer
service calls and voicemails
and in its announcement microsoft said
that nuances technology will be used to
augment
microsoft's cloud products for
healthcare which were launched
last year so one
i think that it's less about buying the
product it's more about buying growth
but that growth comes from owning the
product so we'll agree
right there that there's a directional
thing no not disagree i think we
actually agree more than we disagree
two is i see a lot of talk about this
being artificial intelligence
why this is not artificial intelligence
this is simply
speech to text they're taking spoken
words and they're translating it into
text
amazingly hard to do it's hard to do but
that doesn't make it artificial
intelligence
artificial intelligence literally means
that it's something that can think for
itself
that's not artificial intelligence facts
next microstrategy
had said that its non-employee board
members will now be compensated in
bitcoin and an ak filing with the sec
micro strategy said that from april 11th
onward
non-employee directories on its board
will receive all fees for their service
and bitcoin instead of cash what is
michael saylor
doing michael saylor is a gangster
my guy is out here just pushing
his back has to hurt because he put the
whole team on his back
and he is carrying the squad right now
balance sheet in unsecured loans into
bitcoin in
paying the board directors in bitcoin in
the guy
doesn't stop you love to see it very
smart
very very smart if you need a signal to
show that this company is committed to
their bitcoin strategy
this is a great one and i think that
michael saylor is doing exactly what he
said he's going to do
he's not going to stop he's relentless
he's only going to continue to pursue
this bitcoin strategy
and think that it has proven to be very
very valuable for shareholders and
likely will continue to be
moving forward the university of central
florida which is apparently in orlando
florida
um their new coach gus malzahan
malzahn is allowing
the team to put their twitter handles on
the back of their
jerseys gangster welcome to the future
well two things one is there's a rule
change so now that they can
uh promote and profit from their image
like monetizing themselves
yes very very smart uh an age of
personal branding
one may say gus malzahn's always been a
very player friendly coach he
understands that
when you're in college it's different
than the nfl in the nfl you can pay
people
so you can say hey i want you to come to
my team i'll just pay you more that's
how i get you to come here but when it
comes to college you got to recruit
people you got to show them all the
non-monetary benefits
this is kind of a side door into
monetary benefit though you could say
hey
we're going to make you famous we're
going to help you build your personal
brand
and by doing that you'll then be able to
monetize it off the field
and that's why you should come to our
university so what if somebody has a
really inappropriate twitter handle
would they let them put it on their back
well the thing about college football is
you basically have a bunch of
uh new parents because the coaches don't
want you to do anything inappropriate
so somebody had an inappropriate twitter
handle that would be addressed before it
ever came up should i put this on my
uh uh jersey or not now if
some of you remember the xfl he hate me
what a guy he hate me was the name
somebody put on the back of their jersey
and he used to do it because he's like
when i'm running for the end zone and
you're behind me chasing me you go see
he hate me on the back and that was
literally the name on the back of his
jersey
so do not be surprised that some people
switch up the twitter handles and decide
that they should have a
memorable twitter handle just for this
specific purpose
so do we remember boston dynamics spot
robotic dog that dances and does
backflips and opens doors for its robot
dog friend
well now it's being used by the french
military spot
um has appeared alongside soldiers
during military exercises carried out by
the french army
the robot was apparently being used for
reconnaissance
reconnaissance during a two-day training
exercise
but the deployment raised you look like
a wizard but the deployment raises
questions about how and where boston
dynamics machines
will be used in the future what do we
think about this combat
robot dog i'm just getting close enough
where i can prevent the facial
recognition from getting me
anthony you look like a wizard well no
problem no no i like this like this
this is my public wreck hoodie by the
way public wreck go to publications.com
oh my god we're like public rec dot com
uh
what i think here is the following one
you look so funny robots are absolutely
going to be the future of warfare why
are we going to put human lives at risk
when we just send machines to fight
machines
duh two is that this is reconnaissance
only at the moment which means it's a
non-violent combatant on the battlefield
meaning that it does not carry weapons
wait till you see what they did to the
drones the predators when they actually
put missiles on the predator drones
what happens when they now are going to
put missiles or guns imagine not gatlin
guns
which is the one that goes and shoots
five thousand rounds a minute what
happens when they put that on the little
dog and they're like oh look at the
little dog
okay but to me it's like humans have
morals and ethics and they can make snap
decisions
the dog doesn't have a mind it can't
think for itself exactly no so humans
are still making those decisions yes but
when you're not
there in person right now
it makes it easier to be less ethical
let me tell you about drum
let me tell you about drone warfare let
me tell you about drone warfare
it's asked lunch money time hashtag ask
elem in the comments below
alexander albertsey asks hi pomp
and paulina thanks for the great show
you always talk about the devaluation of
the dollar as well as rising inflation
coming
however what is your opinion of brent
johnson's dollar milkshake theory of
deflation
and a rising dollar over the longer term
outlook
thanks i had brent on the podcast uh
probably a year ago at this point
um like sometime april may of last year
uh it's very interesting theory
very very well named very memorable name
great marketing by brent
i do not agree with it all the milkshake
what
i do not agree with it i do not think
you can get a stronger dollar over time
because you're having a devalued at such
an incredible rate yes there is a
relative
nature to this so if the dollar uh is
being devalued but everything else is
being devalued faster
technically the dollar would be stronger
than the rest of the currencies so there
is some nuance here
uh but i do not agree that the dollar
over the longer
time period is gonna end up having this
dollar milkshake theory
i think what we've actually seen is most
of the value that's getting created is
getting sucked into the crypto economy
and so in some crazy way you shouldn't
call it the dollar milkshake theory you
should call the built
the bitcoin milkshake theory because
really what we're seeing is all
liquidity pushed into the market it's
getting sucked up by store value assets
and bitcoin has been the greatest
beneficiary of that given its small
market cap size at the time
now we're pushing a trillion dollars and
likely to go much much higher
this year also note this is what happens
when you have lunch money at noon
in an audition for lord of the rings at
one
okay um i don't i've never seen that
[ __ ] i haven't either but you look like
gandalf
is that from lord of the rings or am i
making it before you say facts you
should
i love you no no come on come on come on
we're almost done we're almost done
i have things to do it is from lord of
the rings but he doesn't have a hood
yeah he has a hat
yeah okay um moist oh poor moist
day 94 of commenting real recognized
real i know i'll get that email i got
that good friday energy right now too
just went 3-0 and pick up while leading
my team in points every game
no big deal all right while your brother
is with you let him know that moist is a
huge fan and appreciates his
non-partisan
sports journalism as soon as we get done
with this i'm emailing him damn
moist hashtag built different that's
what speaks to me
all right by the way just because you
lead a team in
uh basketball and points doesn't mean
you can beat me in one on one i will
smoke you i don't even know who you are
all right oh my god i almost said love
you guys i mean i do love you guys but
because you know when i end a call all
right can we get these taken off now yes
but not right now
what are they called martinitsa a what
martini it's all my bulgarian friends
obichamte bulgaria tcm nogo cresiva
uh i might even go with a little uh tc
hobo
uh yeah i like you how your hair looks
today
you know i'm just out here spitting
facts
oh beat some tape bulgaria oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
anthony that means i love myself i love
polly and i love
bulgaria we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends